20h08
michel desjoyeaux coupe la ligne
d'arrivée de ce quatrième vendée globe
les sables d'olonne laisse alors éclater
leur joie
son bateau porte le numéro 85
le département de la vendée une victoire
à domicile en quelque sorte
devant un public nombreux qui attend son
héros depuis le milieu de l'après midi
ils ont bravé la pluie bravé le froid et
maintenant c'est la brume qui gênent la
visibilité
peu importe
et puis discrètement sa femme monte à
bord 93 jours que son navigateur de mari
est parti mais elle n'ose pas le
déranger
bientôt l'équipage a grandi photo de
famille avec ses trois garçons
je n'ai pas du tout eu
déjà j'ai failli ne pas le savoir un
bruit je n'ai plus vraiment au dernier
moment alors que j'avais le traceur
avait tout ce qu'il fallait
quelques noms encore où c'était à
reygades comme si c'était un parcours
côtier de l'après midi c'est évident que
toute la proche avec tous les bateaux
derrière c'était vraiment j'ai jamais vu
ça et je crois que là jamais ça de ma
vie un tour du monde
ça laisse forcément des traces et une
fois à terre michel desjoyeaux est un
peu déboussolés
je crois que la terrasse bouge non non
je ratio non mince alouettes mois un
marin qui attend bien encore pendant une
bonne partie de la nuit